what is going on everybody welcome to
another python with pandas sentiment
analysis and finance tutorial video
series
what we well what we did in the last
video is we worked on how to make
dynamic moving averages and now in this
video what i want us to do is actually
take those dynamic moving averages that
we generate
and we want to kind of append this to
our data frames so later we can
reference that
reference what those values are and make
a judgment whether or not we should make
it
an investment or not okay so we're gonna
take our first step towards doing that
also
uh after we get done with that the other
thing i'd like us to do is do some
housekeeping here
as we can see already for
these counts right we've just hard coded
these counts in there
that's kind of silly we really shouldn't
do that we should first of all just have
one variable that
is that determines what those count you
know divisions
are and also we might as well just put
that as a
parameter in our function here and then
we might as well set those as default
parameters
with 275 105 so we don't have to type
them at all but if we wanted to change
them it would only require
one edit to change because this gets
messy really quick and it's poor
poor programming in general to do
something like this so we'll fix that
right away um that way this problem
doesn't get any bigger
so anyway uh that's what we're going to
do here so let's go ahead and get
started
so the first thing we're going to do is
once we've got ma1234 the first thing
that we need to consider is well we're
going to add this to
our data frame but we also want to
ignore
any plots that don't have data for
ma4 since that's our largest moving
average so for example when it's one
hundred two fifty five hundred five
thousand
anything from plot you know one to f uh
five thousand is going to have a
skewed um value for what the five
thousand moving average is right so
there's gonna be no value
in this case um because there's not
enough data
so it's gonna you know save in our data
is not a number or it would just be
blank
either way we're not able to evaluate
whether or not
something is higher than a 5000 moving
average if there is no answer to a 5 000
moving average
so that's the first thing we want to do
if you followed any of my other
tutorials usually what we do to denote
this is
sp so capital s capital p and that just
stands for
starting point so it's how we derive the
starting point of our data that we want
to consider
and so the starting point is going to be
integer
valuation of count
divided by
5.5 okay now the problem here is it
might
make a decimal and we can't so what
we're going to end up doing is we're
going to take that numpy array because
it or
at least the data frame reference and it
kind of translates to a numpy array
we're going to take that numpy array we
want to say colon or we want to say
basically
five thousand colons and from number
five thousand on but
we can't say you know number five
thousand point two five right you can't
have that be a decimal
so we need to convert this decimal to a
whole number now you could use round and
zero
but the problem with that is it might
round down and it would just you know
be slightly inaccurate so let's go ahead
and fix that
and instead um instead of just the
integer of count
five uh count divided by 5.5 what we can
use is math
dot seal and basically that is short for
ceiling and what it's going to do is
it's going to take
any decimal and round it up okay to the
nearest whole number so even a 5.1
rounds up to 6. and in this way maybe we
lose
one row of data but at least we won't be
one row of data too early
so this is the best way to do it in my
opinion so anyway
um we're going to call that ceiling now
the next thing that we want to do is
actually we're going to
define these new columns that we want to
generate so for example
this is going to be df ma1
and that's going to be equal to ma1
okay that defines that new column for us
now let's just go ahead and highlight
this
copy and then paste paste paste and now
we just need to change this to
2 3 4 and again 2
3 and 4. now we have defined these as
columns in our data frame we could save
to csv but we can also continue doing
other mathematical operations
by referencing this column so that's why
we actually want to end up doing that
now once we've done that we've added
these columns now we want to chop off
all of the bad data right i.e the data
before ma4 whatever number that is so
with
apple that would be the first 50 000
lines of data that we want to just
chop off so for this what we're going to
say is df
equals so data frame equals the current
data frame
and then sp colon so the current data
frame from the starting point on
okay makes a whole lot of sense so
that's all we want to do
now we still want to plot the same stuff
and
everything else should be good so let's
go ahead and save and run that
hopefully we don't get any errors from
typos and the like
now while that is running the next thing
i suggest we are going to do
since this might take a little bit to
process is we want to edit
this right here and we want to add those
default parameters that we were
discussing
so we want stock name and we did we got
a
error math is not defined we did not
import math
import math hopefully that would be
enough because we did just
all the only other module we used here
was math.seal right yeah
okay yeah so anyways hopefully that
doesn't hit us again with another error
anyway so in single stock auto ma stock
name
um that's fine then we want a default
parameter of div one
what is div one getting equal um
and then and so on so div one will equal
275
and then we'll say div two equals okay
our chart is up so let me finish writing
this out but the chart came up so div
two equals
110 and now let's pull this chart over
um
what do we do i guess we did apple what
stock is this i can't remember what
stock we're
oh no okay this is google
uh okay so here's google
move this over a little bit okay so um
so we got our uh our plotting uh
everything looks good and if we hit home
it looks to me like we still have that
improper starting point here so let me
go back and look at this df equals sp
colon possibly we're plotting e right
okay so the other thing that we have to
edit here is see
ma1 is referencing back to this
ma1 up here and that's a problem because
actually we want to reference that
column now so instead what we're going
to do is we'll just
take this copy and we're going to do
and actually actually stick the whole
thing df copy
and then click on this paste and then
paste paste
paste then we'll say two three and four
and let me make sure i close that plot i
did not
so close that plot let's go ahead and
rerun it
now while that is processing we'll come
back up here and we're going to continue
making our updates
so we're going to say div 2 equals 110
div 3 equals 55 and finally div
4 equals 5.5 so these are just the
default parameters that we want on this
function now once we've done that we
want to come down here
and we want to change all of these right
so this would be instead of 275 it'll be
div one
okay now let's come back over to our
chart because it came up
make it up here and so now you can see
that this chart oops
this chart is um
what we're hoping for right where the
starting they all all the moving
averages start at the exact same moment
that way we're always working with what
i would say valid
data right okay so we we actually have
that here
and we're happy with that um so
uh that's good so let's close out of
this and let's continue working with
what we need to do for this housekeeping
so we don't have to continue
hard coding stuff so instead of div one
and now i'm just going to copy that
paste
paste and paste so div
2 div 3 and div 4. so those are just
corresponding to the default parameters
in our function here and we've got those
all set as we come down the starting
point okay don't forget this one we've
got a 5.5 that needs to be converted to
a div
4 and then we come down here
do we have any others okay right so here
we've got what needs to be
um see if i saw that paste yeah paste
paste paste
and paste
that needs to be a div 4 div one
this is two and this is a div three
now just as an aside if you wanted to
ever have these other ones be a decimal
don't forget you would need to fix this
right otherwise you're gonna have a
really long decimal there
that would get in the way now this is
only for visualization purposes so
if you don't mind having a really long
decimal in the legend or you can just
not
show the legend that doesn't really
matter because all we're doing here is
just trying to visualize the data so
that we can formulate a strategy
on the data but otherwise it doesn't
really matter what
well how big that
that number or how long that decimal is
rather
so at this point i believe we have
taken out all that all those hard-coded
numbers
uh yeah so let's go ahead and run this
one more time and make sure that that is
you know we're getting the information
that we want
yeah that looks good so whenever this
comes up hopefully we'll have use our
dynamic numbers and then
when you come down here and you call you
know what you want to plot
you could then fill these these
parameters with other numbers
if you wanted but you don't obviously
we're not going to do that right now
but then later on too we could create a
function that calls
these um
that fills in those parameters for us so
like i was saying before if we wanted to
maybe search for a company
the company's best div numbers we could
create a function that would do that
very easily with this function to test
but
anyway more on that later if we go to
that but i'm i'm hoping that we won't
have to go into something like that but
anyways um
so that worked out good so we're
plotting on the dynamic
uh moving averages we're using our
default parameters now instead of hard
coding
and we've got a starting point now um
and so not only is that it was all of
this useful for
data visualization but also for data
manipulation so generally visualization
is really there to help
you the programmer see that everything
is working the way that you intend it to
work
otherwise i mean the computer doesn't
need the visual you know you don't have
to have any visualization for the
computer
it doesn't need it so anyway that was
mostly for us
but the starting point we need that and
then we also want these
dynamic moving averages to not be so
hard coded like they were
so that's going to conclude this
tutorial video if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
those in the section below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time